israelis may soon be able to put away
their vaccine passes for good israel was
one of the first countries to introduce
the past but officials now worry it
could give false assurances the omicron
variant is infecting many who are fully
vaccinated starting sunday the past will
only be required in high risk areas like
hospitals where health care workers are
battling record covet 19 infections
since the early morning jael liron has
been on duty on a covet ward an elderly
patient needs oxygen and some comforting
words
the covet wards at this hospital in tel
aviv are extremely busy
there are a lot of cases
we have new intakes every day when one
is released another is submitted at
night numbers are on the rise we always
experience a delay
even when the general infection rate
seems lower we at the hospital are still
dealing with the higher numbers from the
two weeks previously
though overall omigron infection rates
show signs of slowing down the number of
patients in hospital remains high
israel was one of the first countries in
the world to roll out a rapid
vaccination program
over 65 percent of the population have
been vaccinated twice but only 48 have
had a third booster shot so far
in january those in the most vulnerable
categories were offered a force
during this wave most of our patients
have been elderly it reminds us of the
flu the complications are comparable
people are dying now the way they would
die from the flu
also
fewer people are dying of omicron
most patients on this ward are
vaccinated elderly people with
underlying health conditions
working on the ward is exhausting for
everyone adding to this hospitals like
other institutions are struggling with
staff shortages
due to the highly contagious omigran
variant high numbers of doctors and
nurses are in quarantine
it's difficult it's the fifth time we've
been at full capacity here in israel but
we're dealing with it
that's just how it is as they say and
it's our job to look after patients
but it's definitely hard and there's a
lot of
but yes it's exhausting and it doesn't
look like it's going to end soon
although i'm personally cautiously
optimistic
for now everybody here must keep going
doing the best they can for the ongoing
influx of patients and hoping that the
peak of the current wave will soon
subside
that report by tanya kramer we can take
you now to tel aviv and speak to nadav
davidovich a epidemiologist from the ben
gurion university of the negev professor
welcome to dw news i understand that you
sit on the panel that advises the
israeli government and you've been
critical in the past of some of their
approaches with cases still high in your
country is this the right decision
the green pass actually was introduced
in order to have safe epidemiological
uh it was not introduced in order to
enforce
vaccinations vaccinations are extremely
important they saved in israel according
to
our estimates about
twenty thousand deaths
um but currently with the omicron
and with the fact that people vaccinated
they are safe probably from
hospitalizations and
death but much less so in being infected
so we need to adapt the green pass
uh we don't want to abolish it all
together we want to keep it
also for the future if needed
and currently probably this is best to
have it either as a voluntary measure or
when you have high risk situations such
as hospitals elderly care homes
or
other a high-risk
activities
vaccinations are very very important uh
we are now in a really unprecedented
situation and we need to adapt the
current measures uh to the epidemiology
uh we need to vaccinate we need to still
use their mask of course and
i think that by the fact that we're
adapting the green pass it's very
important also from the trust of the
public right now dr israel has been uh
slowly rolling back curbs is there
widespread support for that
um i think that the current government
you know was
trying to balance
the measures in terms of
keeping as much as you can
the number of cases but remembering the
public health is also about social
support and economy
i think that
currently
we could do much better in terms of
opening schools i think it was an
important
factor but
there was lots of confusion and tension
between the ministry of health and
ministry
of education and there were also
criticism about the economic support
because so many people are in isolation
we're learning to live with uh kovid if
you compare israel situation in other
countries you know to what happened
there about a year ago things are very
different we have
adoption of testing and many other
things we need to learn to live with the
virus because covet is going to stay
with us we're learning that
the fda is going to hear uh pfizer about
having vaccines below the age of five
and i think this will be another
important measure because vaccinations
are going to enter i think
finally into the regular schedule of
children
and
we are going to deal with it and
strengthening the healthcare system as
much as needed they suffered a lot
during the last two years
epidemiologist
nadav davidovich in tel aviv sir thank
you so much for taking the time to
answer our questions
thank you lots of health
you